walk him to this video I'm playing the
Dark Passenger from the US ghana
something and then no okay so i started
with it with the fianchetto maybe if you
and shadow everything some that's very
rarely played but it's a possible set up
it's a bit similar to the Queen's and
again with the exception of the
difference of course that is G 636 C 5
may be interesting the idea ok after d5
I had the idea to play be five okay
maybe just protect c5 not sure that it
was hanging but why not
yeah that's interesting this Bishop move
was threatening to make this night
mobile uh-huh okay so he loves me to
place my night on this quite juicy
square on deform but he's got two
bishops and maybe possibilities to play
against it but again see seven but this
is how to how to get going I'm I'm
trying to open up lines here immediately
yeah it's it's similar to the bank oh of
course but within the fantastic bishop
on d4
ya black ass in excellent shape here no
doubt about that the question is how to
play this in the most precise manner I
think I'll take him I get upon back here
anyway I mean I could have taken bit too
maybe this was more precise
yeah it was more precise definitely yeah
this was bad why didn't I do that just
take on between okay okay seven is some
men to protect e7 yeah this was just
badly played I must take be too of
course yeah I was just I was just
thinking that I get this anyway but this
is nonsense of course
ok we cannot take e seven now because of
tricks on F to be too I don't think it's
advisable to take now I could yeah I
will take take a tool yeah okay I need
to make sure that I get the Queen side
so I have this pressure on f2 the
question is can you play move yep
something like that attacking attacking
down
and take sticks but should be six
something like that but I can always
take him okay let's use this upon mmm I
cannot play then I cannot check the
Queen for this point is not not possible
yet but the seaport is dangerous see
three ball will tell ya this is the way
to try to defend it
rookie too
okay I not sure that he can defend
against the corn and the d5 pawn at the
same time yeah f5 is what i was thinking
about maybe it's a ridiculous
okay I cannot play c2 but at five not at
five if he goes to d3 than that c21
taking okay so i can actually grab the
five check not sure that it is doing so
much but it's better than nothing ok
just King f7 maybe King f7 and rook e8 h
eight
hmm
hmm is this threatening something if not
then now okay it's just
I take him there's only a check that's
not too much
don't see a win it looks like there
should be something but I don't see
anything the check is not so not enough
for some reason
check
don't see when here sick it looks really
bad
just trying to get home of the pin I
didn't I more angles hmm very ugly
not sure this is winning for him I don't
know check here I can go to h6 all the
way please some threatening look h3 and
queen age five mate but maybe I'm just
checking something very simple as
possible
he goes King g2 I'm actually meeting him
but I don't tell I don't think you will
fall for that green g5 from the must
explain
yahoo gauge to is firmly also winning
simply due to the time and I don't have
any time high i just spent far too much
time for this uh yeah yeah I don't know
I sport this sports as far before I mean
it's probably a this is also winning for
black but I shouldn't really allow the
position yeah black is completely
winning actually look before anything
but how did I even allow that yeah yeah
I probably this was everything was fine
but this is actually somewhat tricky
check yeah yeah it is tricky yeah this
wasn't a great move but what does what
was what would not okay no way to find
the computer suggestion look at this
king of eight takes in g5 no simply no I
cannot find this in in a couple of
seconds the idea is to play like this
check yeah insane no way I've ever going
to play that yeah yeah but in in fact
the the situation which is the worse is
that i didn't take on be to hear hear I
just I just need to take him and and
this is just a bad position very bad the
computer actually likes white which what
I don't understand ready what because of
Bishop f1 okay so maybe this model so
terrible
Queenie 8 yeah maybe maybe I only need
to be a bit more precise here because
simply this Bishop is such a monster but
it should be enough to win the game okay
as it as it was played them I am an
excellent shape no question it wasn't so
easy though yeah and I was simply
playing too slowly alright thanks for
watching